SPEAKER: In GKE,
application owners
can define the minimum
and maximum amount
of CPU and memory that
their workloads require.
This is done in the form of per
container requests and limits
in a Kubernetes pod.
This process isn't
perfect though.
Workload requirements
may need to change over
time for many reasons,
from incoming demand
on the applications to
improper initial configuration.
App right-sizing is a practice
of fine tuning workload
requests over time to ensure
that their requests accurately
reflect what the
workloads will utilize.
In order to make GKE cost
optimization a discipline,
it's important to
provide a monitoring
system that can help teams
practice app right-sizing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Previously, we
discussed how it is
important to monitor
cluster bin packing,
or how efficiently resources
are distributed at a cluster
and node pool level.
Signals of poor utilization
at these aggregated levels
can be indicative of
applications being
over or under provisioned.
Monitoring at the
application level
can empower application
owners to have
the right data to
right-size their apps
and put GKE cost
optimization into practice.
To monitor this
effectively, we want
to ensure that
clusters utilize name
spaces in a logical fashion.
For many reasons, we do not
want to have a single namespace
running all pods.
These include overly permissive
role-based access control,
inability ability to set quotas
for team, the list goes on.
But from a monitoring
perspective,
we want to be able
to utilize namespaces
to understand app right-sizing
patterns across groups
of applications.
A common example of how
this could be useful
would be for namespaces to
be aligned to each team.
This easily allows us to
then chart and monitor
how each team is doing.
For example, when a
team is consistently
overprovisioned on a specific
resource across multiple apps,
we can make that information
available to them.
This builds a culture
around empowering teams
to right-size their apps.
The way we can detect
how well they're doing,
is by utilizing
platform-specific
recommendations.
For example, the
vertical pod autoscaler.
This means that we'll
get recommended values
for CPU and memory
requests, which
we can chart against
the actual resources
that pods are requesting
in that given namespace.
Once we have a team to work
with on right-sizing apps,
we can then dig into monitoring
for their overprovisioned apps.
The data we've already collected
for the aggregate namespace
view will be utilized here as
well, this time on a per work
load basis.
Here, we can see that the
front end and back end
workloads for team A are
well over provisioned.
So what can we do now?
We can start with auto
generated recommendations
from vertical pod autoscaler.
This may give us
quick, easy guidance
to right-size overprovisioned
apps by reducing CPU and memory
requests.
We should also create per
application dashboards
where we graph out
data, including
what resources the
pods are utilizing,
what the sum of requests and
limits for those pods are,
and how their
utilization compares
to their target utilization
defined by a horizontal pod
autoscaler.
Note that in this example,
we have the horizontal pod
autoscaler's target
utilization for a set of pods
well above actual utilization.
This introduces an opportunity
for cost optimization
by app right-sizing.
When we have average utilization
well below the target
utilization defined in the
horizontal pod autoscaler,
we can consider lowering the
number of minimum replicas.
By reducing this
count, we get to reduce
the cost of running
this application,
all while maintaining
flexibility to still scale up
to handle varying load.
While we have mainly
focused on cost optimization
with the goal of
reducing cluster costs,
it's a good time
to remind ourselves
that cost optimization
and practicing
FinOps is the
discipline of balancing
cost with other critical areas.
With this same data,
we can also monitor
for under provisioned
apps as well,
which are opportunities for
right-sizing apps for the sake
of performance and stability.
Over time, you'll find that
cluster bin packing and app
right-sizing are
intertwined exercises
due to events such as the
onboarding of entirely new apps
into a cluster.
Configuring a monitoring system
around the topics discussed
here can be complex, so be
sure to check out the guide we
published on how to set one up.
With a system set up for
cluster bin packing and app
right-sizing, you can
ensure that your team will
be able to continuously practice
cost optimization for your GKE
clusters.